Hey, Vsauce. Michael here.
And today I released a brand new
Vsauce Leanback. A playlist of
educational videos from all over YouTube
that I think are cool
and I host sort of like a Vsauce TV show.
You can start that by clicking the box up in
the corner
or the link at the top of this video's
description. But before that,
I wanna talk about the Shepard tone.
It's a sound
made out of multiple sine waves that
play a trick on us.
See, what they do is continuously rise in pitch
and then every so often one of them
drops down an octave,
but our brains don't perceive that because
the other two
continue rising and cover for it.
The sine waves take turns dropping down an
octave,
producing a sonic barber pole, a noise
that appears to keep rising in pitch for
ever and ever
without ever actually going anywhere.
I was reminded of it this week by
FallingFalling.com,
a creation of Internet artist New Rafael,
where the Shepard tone
seems to go down and fall forever.
Rafael also made some other cool sites,
like OutInTheWind.com.
Here, there's nothing except for dismissing
wind that slowly erodes your cursor. Okay, now
some of you may already know this, but in
America
we say "ADIdas," whereas the rest of the world says
"adiDAS." And no, it does not stand for "all
day I dream about soccer."
That's just a backronym, an acronym made
up for a word that already exists.
Instead, it's named after a person, which
is why people pronounce "adiDAS."
It's named after Adi Dassler, a German guy
who got in a fight with his brother,
so his brother rude off, went across the
river and started his own athletic company,
known as PUMA.
That's right. Adidas
and Puma came from the same town,
from the same
family. Finally, before the Leanback, I
wanna share this USB typewriter with you.
It's a really cool device
that plugs into your computer and works
like a normal keyboard, except at the
same time
it keeps a hard copy for your records.
It even works with an iPad.
Alright, now it's time to watch the
Vsauce Leanback. You can click here
to start it.
I'll meet you over there.
And as always,
thanks for watching.